As entrepreneurs are trying to build
our their e-commerce business,
it's really important to
understand the impact
mobile devices had on
commerce in general.
For a long time,
it was thought that purchasing
on a mobile phone can't happen.
You have to type in all
this extra information.
But more and
more it's becoming really obvious
that that's where people
are spending all of their time.
So in the same way people were shopping
online on their PC's a long time ago,
now a lot of that commerce
happens on the phone.
So, it's really important to really
think about how do you optimize your
experience, and your purchase experience
specifically, for the mobile device.
And so things like thinking
about how can you auto fill
information based off of what's
already in your phone built in there?
And thinking about,
as you're actually have different
interactions with your website.
Think about how much space do I actually
have on this screen to actually
fit in all the different buttons.
Like if you want to offer reviews,
like the ability to choose color,
ability to choose size.
Like ability to sort of switch
between a lot of different images of
the same product.
One of the things that you realize
is that you have to make trade offs.
And the only way you
can really understand
how to make those trade-offs
is through testing.
And really figuring out,
if I have this button here, which takes
up the full screen, or opposed to having
two different buttons on that screen.
How does that impact
the conversion rate?
Because of the focus more and
more on the mobile device.
Testing becomes more and more important
because you don't have all that much
real estate to actually work with.